so let's say someone's 25 right now and
they say you know what i know exactly
the type of film i want to make and i
can do it myself and i can shoot it for
cheap why should i learn about history
what can that teach them knowing going
back to 1895 or or maybe even a few
years before then to to know the the
sentiment of the the era what can that
show them why should they know more
about the whole history of how film
began
well i think it helps you uh sort of see
yourself uh
as
people always been somebody struggling
and attempting to find
a way through a puzzling problem
and it helps you see that others have
been there too
that you're not the first you're not the
first one to get up in the middle of
night and say oh my god what have i done
or isn't that beautiful
others have had exactly that same
thought and amazingly
the others who thought that often have
turned out to be famous great you know
giants
but when they were doing it they didn't
know what the act they were doing
uh and i think it can be very
liberating and odd way
to come to understand how much struggle
there was
for the first people
to do this kind of stuff it kind of
gives you courage
your site is called film courage and i
got to tell you that it is really
profoundly encouraging
to
sit there and just think about movie
making from the point of view where the
people are doing it for the first time
and attempting to figure out well
how do i put sounds
on top of a moving image and not confuse
people or
how do i chop up a scene
so that
i increase its excitement and energy in
action because no one's done this before
so that's what i think you can get out
of it it can give you
sort of it can embolden you
because it realizes that
all artists are really struggling with
the same thing it's always everybody's
always at the frontier no matter where
you are
it's always the newest thing there's
always some kind of technology that
people are messing with and don't quite
understand
uh and so that's what i think you can
learn it can in a weird way
make you not afraid
that's what i when i think